It's a new type of birthing pod ma'am
that my child is the next step in
our evolution more powerful more beautiful
more capable of destroying the Guardians of the Galaxy
I think I shall call him.
Adam
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 Adam Warlock video
I'll explain what's going on with him in the MCU
was the future of the character because this is
going to be the last movie with this roster of the
Guardians of the Galaxy but the team will continue
on Adam Warlock will continue on as a really big
character in the MCU he's one of the most powerful
characters that Marvel's ever introduced if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll get more trailer videos
really soon too they just released the first
trailer online it's been around for a while but
they finally released it online so we don't have
the janky potato quality footage anymore so they
give us a preview of what he actually looks like
in the movie but just explaining his origin in
the MCU how that's different from the comics
and what's going to be different about him going
forward the movie is meant to pick up just after
the events of the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special like a little bit of time has gone by but
not a lot of time the size of Groot is a good way
to Benchmark the timeline of the team like how
much bigger his Groot got in this movie and he's
meant to be about the same size that he was during
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special even
though he does have a couple moments during the
trailer where he gets super slow has his version
of a Hulk out moment where he does we are Groot
but this time it's him going back to back with
Star-Lord fighting people the reason why his
voice sounds different is because he's meant to
be the son of the previous Group which is another
change from the comics in the comics it's just
like regrowing himself from different parts of
his body I'll talk more about Groot in future
videos but Adam warlock's story in the MCU is
also meant to flow with that theme of families
when things pick up in the movie Adam Warlock
will have just finished gestating in his cocoon
which is meant to be similar to his comic book
cocoon but obviously his origin is just a little
bit different in the comics he was created by an
evil group called The Enclave for the purpose of
Conquering the world as a way to battle all the
superheroes that they saw flying around the funny
thing about the way they created him is it was
actually similar to the way the Ultron created
Vision in the special tank that The Enclave
bombards with a bunch of solar energy to power him
up the whole thing with the cocoons came after his
first big adventure after they introduced him and
he rebelled Against The Enclave defeated them and
went off on his own to discover everything kind
of learn everything because he was literally
born yesterday which is also very similar to what
happened with vision's Creation in the MCU well
I was born yesterday the Marvel comic
book writers had to explain where he
was when he wasn't around in the comics
so they explained that he just created
a cocoon and regenerated himself in the MCU
the group that created him is The Sovereign
Ayesha which explains why he's gold like he was in
the comics and if it wasn't clear during Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 they didn't spend too much time
getting into the backstory of The Sovereign race
but all the members of their race are created
like this it's just that they don't get as much
power as Adam Warlock got their race basically
tampers with their own genome to create more
perfect versions of themselves throughout time so
each one is meant to be like this perfect being
the difference with the creation of Adam Warlock
is that Ayesha wanted to go way above and beyond
the work that they'd done creating other members
of their race to make him even more powerful for
the express purpose of killing the Guardians
of the Galaxy so like The Enclave in the comics
bombarding his body with solar cosmic energy a
yeshu in The Sovereign bombardant Adam warlock's
cocoon with a bunch of their battery energy that
they collect those special batteries the Guardians
of the Galaxy stole creating the whole reason why
they want to make Adam Warlock in the first place
what are they called again annulax batteries
Harvey Larry batteries but there were thousands
of units a piece which is why the Sovereign hired
us to protect them one of the other big changes
in his origin story is that a yesha in the MCU is
the one that gives him the name Adam she doesn't
give him the Warlock name that might come later
when the Guardians of the Galaxy encounter him
but originally in the comics when he was created
he didn't have an actual name they just referred
to him as him like that guy but one of the big
reasons why they're doing Adam Warlock in the
same movie is the high evolutionary in the MCU
is because they have a deep Connection in the
comics Adam Warlock was created to be the perfect
being in the high evolutionaries whole mission
is that he's trying to create the perfect life
that's why he's performing all these experiments
creating these humanoid looking animals on his
version of counter Earth than the MCU and in the
comics after Adam Warlock went off on his own
to just discover learn everything around the
universe he encountered the high evolutionary
on counter Earth who gave him the name warlock
he was just called warlock at first in the high
evolutionary further upgraded him giving him the
soul gem in his forehead and used him to defeat
man Beast one of his Creations on counter Earth
the other regular people living there treated him
like a messiah and this was Roy Thomas the comic
book writer at the time treating Adam Warlock
more like a space Jesus those people gave him the
name Adam which was meant to be another Biblical
reference like the biblical Christian version of
Adam and thus he got his full name Adam Warlock
there was also some inspiration taken from real
life David Bowie in the creation of the character
just in his visual appearance in the MCU the other
connection there is that the guardian's new
ship is called the Bowie after David Bowie
so in the MCU The Sovereign hatch Adam Warlock
and then fill him with all this information saying
that the Guardians of the Galaxy are this evil
group of villains that he has to kill that's all
he's been created for You Must Destroy them he
chases them down and in a couple of the scenes
in the trailer it looks like they're fighting in
a couple different places like one of the places
looks like nowhere which the Guardians now own
they purchased it from The Collector it also
seems like he might fight them at the high
evolutionary is counter Earth base too so we
might see MCU Adam Warlock crossing paths with
MCU High evolutionary so he could get his Adam
Warlock name from MCU High evolutionary but I am
expecting the Guardians themselves to have a hand
in giving him at least part of his name MCU Adam
warlock's origin story also meant to flow with
the themes of the movie In general the whole idea
of the abusive family you're born into versus the
better family you create for yourself obviously
this movie focusing more on Rockets bad space
dad the high evolutionary but all the Guardians of
the Galaxy movies are about bad space dads which
I said before like Thanos ego The Living Planet
we haven't learned a ton about groot's backstory
the original groot's backstory but James going
to say that it's very similar to the comic book
backstory in that the original Groot was banished
by his people a long time ago that's how he came
to meet rocket and then they eventually wound up
joining the Guardians of the Galaxy maybe they'll
address that during this movie or some Future
movie at some point in the case of Anna warlock in
the MCU it's an abusive mother Ayesha feeding all
this hate into him right after he's born he's sort
of like a blank slate when he's born this Ultra
powerful being that's in need of programming like
I need information about everything it's kind of
like vision and him having to decide for himself
what is right and what is wrong and it's a little
bit like nebula's story in the Guardians of the
Galaxy movies she eventually deals with all of her
past trauma and realizes that Thanos was a really
bad person James Gunn said by the events of this
movie She's become much more socially adjusted
much more of a leader character just better at
being with people in general she's still meant
to be hardcore it's kind of like Drax like Drax
is meant to be a good person but he still seems
crazy during a lot of these trailers scenes like
we gotta kill a whole bunch of people and Peter
Cool's trying to stop him like no no we're not
going to kill anybody but even though they're
probably de-powering Adam Warlock a little bit
from the comics like he's not quite as powerful as
he is in the comics he's still way more powerful
than all the Guardians which is why you see him
laying into nebula here so a big part of his story
is the Guardians trying to win him over before
he manages to kill them all a lot of you asking
what's going on with the Soul Stone and the gem
that's in his forehead because in the comics like
I said the high evolutionary gave him the soul gem
giving him this huge power up but Adam Warlock was
a huge part of that story he wielded The Infinity
Gauntlet he became part of the infinity watch this
super powerful group of cosmic characters that
went around trying to protect all of reality
around the universe because of what Thanos
did with the Infinity Stones in present day the
geminist forehead and the MCU serve some of the
same purpose as the Soul Stone did in the comics
but it's more of a focusing Crystal that helped
him absorb all the energy while he was gestating
in his cocoon because you have the Sovereign
bombarding him with all this cosmic energy that
they're collecting in these batteries that's how
he became so powerful part of the idea with Thanos
atomizing the Infinity Stones is he didn't just
blow them up into a cloud of Infinity Stones and
then walk off the essence of the Infinity Stones
dispersed across the entire universe so every
atom of the Infinity Stones spread across the
universe making it nearly impossible for anyone to
reform them but the MCU changed with Adam Warlock
is kind of similar to what they did with white
Vision when sword tried to reform his original
body without the Mind Stone the new gem in white
vision's forehead replacing that is more like the
focusing Crystal for his beam weapon in the
comics Vision didn't even have the Mind gem
he just had a sun Crystal that helped him absorb
more power that he could also use to fire blasts
of energy but after Adam Warlock defeated man
beast on counter Earth he went off to have more
Cosmic Adventures they did the Mages Saga with
Jim Starlin most known for creating the Thanos
character doing The Infinity Gauntlet storyline
that they adapted for Infinity war and Avengers
end game and much later they did the annihilation
Conquest storyline where the new Guardians of the
Galaxy team forms in Adam Warlock winds up
working with them James Gunn based the MCU
version of the Guardians team on that team so
that's why I think he's trying to set up the
idea that this version of MCU Adam Warlock will
join the next Guardians of the Galaxy Roster he
said that this movie is meant to be the last movie
with this particular roster of the Guardians but
not the last movie with the Guardians in it at
all like it's not meant to be the end of their
team they will continue on to the MCU with just
different members a lot of his marketing said one
last time but that's a reference to some of the
characters either dying or going off so probably
going to be a couple big deaths during the movie
people getting really worried about rocket based
on some of the trailer shots I also think this is
part of the reason why James Gunn casts someone
who's so young for Adam Warlock rather than an
older actor so that whoever wound up playing
him could play the character for a long time in
the MCU because he is a huge character even if
he's going to be a little bit different in the
MCU version Adam warlock's next big appearance
will probably be in Avengers 6 Secret Wars in
a smaller role just because there's so many
characters that are going to be in that movie you
have Fox Marvel characters X-Men regular Avengers
from Earth like the new Avengers team and Dead
characters that are coming back as Multiverse
versions like Robert Downey Jr coming back after
that during Marvel phase 7 we don't know a ton
about the future of Marvel's space space movies
other than they're going to introduce more Cosmic
characters like Nova Silver Surfer Galactus the
shiar empire in the next couple of years some of
those characters might debut before Secret Wars
but they're like a lot of really big space-based
Cosmic characters that still haven't debuted
yet that we'll see pretty soon so there are a
lot of space-based movies that they could do just
aside from doing a guard Guardians of the Galaxy
4 movie the next couple of years though it sounds
like their plan just based on what James Gunn is
saying is it the new roster of the Guardians will
be featured in smaller ways like in Thor love and
thunder there's a little bit of the Guardians of
the Galaxy and in the future space based movies
it'll just be the new roster being that Cameo and
Adam warlock's Arc will be a little bit like white
Vision like nebula's Arc relearning everything
like slowly becoming a more well-adjusted person
I don't know if they have any plans to do any of
the Mages storyline in the MCU just because it's
so religious and Marvel tends to shy away from
stories like that and I don't know if they plan on
doing a live-action version of infinity watch then
we'll be a little bit more likely really badass
but I'm not going to hold my breath for it just
because that was so rooted in the infinity stone
storyline and they've kind of moved past that in
the MCU but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with Adam Warlock
in the MCU after Guardians of the Galaxy 3. I
will do a bigger video on the high evolutionary
later this week so be sure to enable alerts from
my channel so you don't miss that there's a bunch
of other stuff that dropped in the past week just
because it was kind of trailer Fest for Brazil
Comic-Con ccxp everyone click here for my full
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video and click
here for my new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!